Working in the lab and me
I'm thinking about security
Glasses down, and put on a lab coat
Open shoes out
Are you kidding ?
Things could go wrong
My gloves
Protects me from chemicals
Chemicals
My dear
Tie back your hair and prepare materials
Materials
First: Don't taste or smell
You know you should sniff your hand
Second: Don't mix it
Until you check the sacks again
Third: No food or drink
If you don't want us to find you dead in the morning
And if you respect it
You reduce the risk
I have lab rules and count them
Tie long hair for yourself
Now go and tell your friends.
First: Don't taste or smell
You know you should sniff your hand
Second: Don't mix it
Until you check the sacks again
Third: No food or drink
If you don't want us to find you dead in the morning
And if you respect it
You reduce the risk
I have lab rules and count them